the streets in the music industry
they're not the same uh people in the
music industry talk about the streets
if that dude that was doing the talking
about the streets really did those
things his ass would be in the
penitentiary be incriminating himself
right because most of the people who are
actually doing that as you've seen over
the last couple of years they've they
got rico charges
it's quick
i mean who scheisse is sitting down
right now one of the hardest rappers in
the world shout out to nephi too good
dude good youngster man send my respects
to his father and his family but um
so
i've never personally seen
the exacts on the 50th floor
say listen today
we're gonna determine if if a little
d-dog get put on the hood
i've never seen that conversation on the
50th floor
right
and i've also seen them say
you two dirty in them streets that come
to the 50th floor
right so street business in street
politics is just that right that's what
it is
you catch me trying to take uh six nine
to somebody neighborhood shoot the video
uh you know uh
some crazy [ __ ] like that i'm in total
violation right i would never even bring
my homeboys who will follow me into the
fire
around that because that's not that's
not their thing they're not part of the
business they'll be there with me right
so whatever it is i did choose to do
with him that's why i was nobody with me
with my wife and kids which i said day
one you know my daughter's a fan that's
what that is you know she don't give a
[ __ ] about none of that of course right
um
but if i got an attorney on the 50th
floor and he got my email and i got his
email and there's an email attached to
him and attorney says hey i see this is
this is available just something that he
may want to do and my attorney's talking
to me and this business i'm definitely
gonna conduct that business
i'm not the guy to say
[ __ ] six nine i wanna see him starve to
death i wanna see him die today and
never make another dime
i can say that that's not realistic
he's what he represents to his fans is
bigger than me
i'm not his fan base so what's driving
his revenue is gonna continue to drive
his revenue whether what we think about
it or not it don't matter you know what
i'm saying right so i'm a businessman